[Musique]
pourquoi plus le temps passe plus j'ai
une tête d'un personnage de dessin animé
comment allez vous messieurs dames une
fois de plus j'ai un casque dans une
vidéo où je ne fais pas écouté une seule
fois un truc âge le mais comment mais
une casquette quoi messieurs dames
aujourd'hui je vous racontais l'histoire
de quelqu'un une histoire qui m'a
fasciné peut-être en avez vous déjà
entendu parler mais peut-être vous
connaissez cette histoire de très loin
c'est celle de andre the giant peut-être
connaissez-vous ce nom de plus ou moins
loin mais aujourd'hui je vous racontais
un peu en détail son histoire parce que
je la trouve hyper touchante ensuite
c'est un gars qui avait l'air
profondément gentil et surtout il avait
un gros handicap et il en a fait sa
force et je trouve ça hyper respectable
et beau andré il fait partie de ces gens
qui ont vécu un truc fou c'est qu'ils
ont méga percée mais dans leur pays
natal pas trop ou alors on sait même pas
qu'ils sont français quand je dis ça je
pense par exemple à yale qui marche
super bien à l'étranger qui fait des
bons sons et en france elle est sous
côté dingue je pense à dj snake où
beaucoup de gens ne savent même pas
qu'ils les français et je trouve ça
vachement marrant on est les pros pour
snober les gens parmi nous qui ont tout
[ __ ] à l'international strauss bref
andré rené hauss imhoff aka andré the
giant à tout [ __ ] à l'international
dans les années 70 c'est devenu l'un des
catcheurs préférés du monde
alors peut-être que vous connaissez pas
grand chose au catch moi c'est le cas
chez juste entendu parler quand j'étais
plus petit de rey mysterio de batista
qu'a fini acteurs dont les gardiens de
la galaxie j'ai rien compris à ce qui
s'est passé j'ai appris aussi que the
rock était en fait catcheur avant d'être
the rocks au cinéma bref aux us c'est
encore une giga communauté autour du
catch en france aussi mais elle est plus
petite qu aux usa
andré c'est devenu aux etats unis une
super star mais déjà commençons par le
début
andré n'est donc en france à coulommiers
en seine-et-marne et à la naissance il
fait 5 kg 8 c'est bon c'est le poids des
haltères que je soulève tous les jours
c'est bon pour vous donner un ordre
d'idée un bébé à la naissance pèse en
moyenne entre 2 kg 6 et 4 kg donc dès la
naissance en dresser un sacré morceau
à tel point que sa mère est obligé
d'aller accoucher à l'hôpital plutôt que
d'accoucher à la maison comme elle l'a
fait pour ses deux frères et soeurs
avant lutte parce que oui on est en 46
et à l'époque c'est hyperfréquences
d'accoucher chez soi bref andré et
grandi à meaux liant en france dans la
demeure familiale
donc là bas c'est la campagne c'est
deschamps on vit de l'agriculture et son
père et donc fermiers c'est une famille
modeste il manque pas de nourriture ils
sont bien nourris par contre c'est pas
non plus la folie ils ont pas un train
de vie extravagant à noël ils n'ont pas
déjoué ils ont des oranges n'y a pas de
bus qui t'amène à l'école donc ils font
un kilomètre 5 pour y aller un kilomètre
5 pour rentrer à pied tous les jours de
l'année bref c'est une famille modeste
alors à l'école andré il est bon élève
il est très bon en mathématiques
je sais pas pourquoi mais à cette news
dans tous les arts
que j'ai lu sur andré donc je vous la
donne comme ça ça fera peut-être qui
fait les fans de mathématiques shebab
faut savoir quand 46 l'école est
obligatoire que jusqu'à 14 ans est
arrivée à 14 ans andré il voit pas trop
l'intérêt de poursuivre un cursus
scolaire parce qu'il veut devenir
ouvrier agricole et que son père peu
vachement l'idée est aussi petite
particularité dont je n'ai pas parlé
depuis le début de cette vidéo andré à
14 ans il fait un mètre 92 et il pèse 92
kg vous l'avez à l'ordre et à l'époque
dans la cour emarrakech de l'ofs ma
maison et mes parents avec mais je vous
le rappelle son père et fermiers et les
pas con il se dit mon fils a des
aptitudes physiques hors normes
ce serait un bon atout dans ma ferme
andré va donc bossé pendant plusieurs
années avec son père dans la ferme
familiale où en gros sont à ça va être
de transporter des sacs de céréales de
110 kilos de couper des arbres et faire
des livraisons dans les villages voisins
grâce à son physique il aurait
apparemment fait pendant ces années le
travail de trois hommes à lui seul
je crois pour un fermier à l'époque tu
pouvais pas mieux rêver qu'un andré
c'était le rêve pendant ces années-là
andré veut aussi suivre un apprentissage
en menuiserie puis va bosser dans une
usine qui fabrique des moteurs alors
c'est que des trucs manuel des petits
jobs par ci par là mais à l'époque
c'était plutôt normal en fait quand
avait 14 ans d'arrêter ses études et
d'enchaîner les petits jobs pour aider
ses parents il passe alors son service
militaire et vu sa corpulence on se dit
qu'il sera un vrai atout dans l'armée
française qui sera colonel et qu'il
imposera le respect non pas une seconde
l'armée le réforme parce que aucun
uniforme ne lui va et qu'ils ne veulent
pas lui en faire un sur mesure à
l'époque les gens qui avaient un
handicap on savait prendre soin d'eux on
était vachement à l'aise andré continue
donc d'aider son père à la ferme
familiale
et d'enchaîner les petits boulots mais
un jour tout bascule
étienne syrie le manager d'une école de
lutte est passage avec sa femme dans le
petit village de la ferté sous jouarre
un big up à tous ceux qui habitent
là-bas qui nous regardent et là il
tourne la tête et sur quel spectacle
tombe sur [ __ ] d'andré en train de
couper un arbre
autant vous dire j'aimerais pas être cet
arbre etienne est fasciné par ce
spectacle et n'en revient pas et il va
donc aller voir andré et lui proposer de
se mettre à la lutte dans son école à
paris andré connais de nom la discipline
mais il n'a jamais vu un match de lutte
puisque ses parents n'avaient pas de
télévision et n'achetez pas le journal
mais ça fait plusieurs années déjà qu'il
enchaîne les petits boulots qu'il tourne
un peu en rond il passe donc son permis
et ils emménagent dans la capitale on
est en 1965
andré à 18 ans et il est pas mal en
galère puisqu'il suit sa formation pour
devenir lutteur mais ça lui rapporte pas
d'argent et pourtant il a un loyer à
payer
il est tellement galère qui passe
certaines nuits à dormir dans des
stations de métro il va donc décider la
journée de bosser en tant que déménageur
et garde du corps pour des prostituées
dans le quartier rouge à pigalle et de
suivre sa formation la nuit les mois
passent et de fil en aiguille andré
rencontre franck valoir un ancien
catcheur devenu manager et qui va être
son nouvel entraîneur le 25 janvier 1966
donc finalement très peu de temps après
qu'il arrive à paris andré obtient son
premier match de lutte officielle sur
les affiches on l'appelle pas andré on
l'appelle le géant ferré en référence à
un paysan au 14e siècle corée buts et 85
envahisseurs anglais à coups de hache en
défendant le château de
longueil-sainte-marie pas mal niveau
marketing 10 était bon et aussi la fiche
indique ses mensurations de m onze pour
cent cinquante kilos pointures du 58 tr
match tuque les fous au cul mon pote
évidemment en voyant la fiche tout le
monde se dit mais qui est ce mec bordel
c'est un véritable colosse et c'est donc
le début de la carrière d'andré on parle
de lui en angleterre en allemagne et
même en nouvelle zélande je sais pas
comment c'est arrivé jusque là bas deux
ans après en 1968 il devient champion de
france de catch dans la catégorie poids
lourd alors depuis le début de cette
vidéo on parle de son incroyable
physique mais on parle pas de la cause
de cet incroyable physique et cette
cause c'est une maladie d'ailleurs on
n'est même pas sûr d'à quel moment
réellement il l'a appris mais ce serait
apparemment en 1970 lorsqu'il a percé au
japon et il était là bas pour combattre
il aurait vu un médecin pour faire des
contrôles de routine et ce médecin lui
aurait appris qu'il est en fait atteints
d'acromégalie
en gros sont hypophyse produit trop
d'hormones de croissance et donc il
continue de grandir et de prendre de la
masse il a aussi un visage assez
particulier qu'est liés à cette maladie
et c'est une maladie très rare qui
touche seulement 0 0 005 % de la
population aux jeunes d'avoir un flash
du truc au cinéma là le mec sur son
ticket la qui vole elle
[Musique]
j'ai jamais compris à quoi elles servent
le numéro téléphone
est-ce qu'on avait des places gratuites
je ne pense pas
alors l'acromégalie en plus de faire de
toi un véritable géant ce qui est très
handicapant au quotidien vous en doutez
ne serait ce que le regard des gens
andré a raconté plusieurs fois à
l'époque bas qu'ils en souffrent et
puisqu'il pouvait jamais tranquille il
attirait toujours l'attention où qu'il
aille en plus de ça les objets du
quotidien des truc tout con les chaises
les lits les téléphones bas ne sont pas
aux proportions idéales pour un mec de
la carrure d'andré mais le vrai problème
surtout c'est que ta santé décline en
vieillissant c'est à dire que tu es plus
en plus propice à avoir de gros
problèmes aux articulations à avoir
d'hypertension avoir des maux de tête et
que si tu te fais pas opérer
généralement ton expérience de vie elle
est estimée à 40 ans puisque ton coeur
fini par lâcher alors on peut se faire
opérer quand on a cette maladie on peut
se faire opérer il ya un pourcentage de
chances de réussite et ça augmente quand
même considérablement ton expérience de
vie mais andré lui en apprenant qu'il a
cette maladie
il décide de ne rien faire ce qui est un
choix très couru en fait il a peur que
ça compromette sa naissance carrière et
son mode de vie et lui il veut vivre la
vie avec un grand v et c'est ce qui va
faire
il arrive aux états unis et comme là bas
les gens ne connaissent pas la légende
du géant ferré puisque c'est une légende
française c'était un français il va être
nommé on sait pas exactement parking
mais les gens vont se mettre à la pelé
andré ce jaye et parallèlement après son
premier match aux us il va être repéré
par vince mac marronne qui est nul autre
que le fondateur de la wwf donc la
fédération mondiale de catch qui
s'appelle maintenant wwe il observe
andré pendant une semaine et le signe et
voir andré un potentiel énorme il veut
faire de lui une figure emblématique du
catch et andré fait alors ses débuts
dans la wwf à philadelphie et c'est là
où il va commencer à tout baiser on est
en 73 il a donc 27 ans son corps a
continué de grandir il fait maintenant
deux mètres 24 et pèse 240 kg bon en
tout cas il est tellement mastoc camp 75
est une équipe de football américaine
qui lui propose de rejoindre l'équipe et
d'être en ligne défensive contre 125
mille dollars par mois mais les gars
pourquoi vous tenter andré lui ce qu'il
veut c'est mettre des bottes portées
ainsi permettre des grands coups de
chaise à ses adversaires
le tout sous une foule en délire du coup
il refuse la proposition de l'équipe de
football et continue de monter et en 76
et participe à un événement qu'est une
soirée boxeur versus catcheur et notre
andré nationale partage l'affiché avec
mohamed ali et chuck baker qui est le
boxeur qui a inspiré le film rocky andré
il a énormément de succès et c'est pas
juste parce que c'est un géant sur le
ring c'est parce que toute l'histoire
qui est créé autour de lui est cool et
surtout toutes ses apparitions sur la
scène maîtrisée et dégage un truc
vraiment sympathique et apparemment dans
la vraie vie il était sympathique
c'était vraiment un bon gars bon vivant
très bon mood
il a aussi invité dans plusieurs late
show américain donc des shows qui font
de sacrées audience dont un dans lequel
il va confirmer les rumeurs à son égard
sur sa capacité à boire de l'alcool à
huy savoie va avec sa carrure et je vous
ai pas prévenu il ya eu plein de rumeurs
sur sa dont certaines qui sont vraies
comme il est très grand bain il peut
beaucoup plus encaissé l'alcool que nous
et il peut facilement boire trois
bouteilles de vin sans être au sol comme
on serait tous
à tel point d'ailleurs qu'il a joué en
france dans une pub pour une bière
voyons le gain en tout cas moi j'ai
rempli la taille de sa main bordel on
arrivait en 1981 il est clairement
devenu l'une des vedettes du catch
mondiale y mène la belle vie
mais peu à peu le temps passe et sa
maladie le rattrape dans les années 80
et commence donc à avoir sérieusement
mal aux articulations surtout au genou
mais aussi aux dauphins tous les trucs
qui doivent soutenir son poids énorme
est clairement de voir tomber et portait
des mecs pour les balancer hors du ring
à répétition ça a pas dû l'aider
du coup maintenant pour lui faire du
catch basse et souffrir en fait c'est un
vrai moment de souffrance mac marronne
son entraîneur est donc le boss de la
wwf voit qu andré va mal et va pas tenir
le coup et organise donc sa succession
et qui il choisi comme successeur
hulk hogan n'est alors toute une
histoire de rivalité entre andre the
giant et hulk hogan qui va rendre le
catch encore plus populaire qu'il ne
l'était déjà
malgré la douleur andré continue de
monter sur le ring qui continue
d'enchaîner les matches et le fait
surtout pour faire kiffer les fans
en fait il ça avec beaucoup de gens
l'aimaient et voulait vraiment les
régaler jusqu'au bout et donc c'est ce
qu'il a fait pour vous donner un ordre
d'idée ils en chient est tellement qu'en
87 quand il a joué dans le film the
princess bride
il devait porter une comédienne dans une
scène sauf que ça lui faisait tellement
mal qu'il ne pouvait pas et ils ont dû
attaché la comédienne à des câbles pour
simuler le fait qu'andré la porte
à titre de comparaison dix ans avant
andré porter quatre personnes à bout de
bras tranquillement donc oui son corps
devient de plus en plus faibles et les
efforts qu'ils doivent faire pour monter
sur le ring sont colossaux bref 1987 il
fait le plus grand match de l'histoire
de sa carrière la rivalité entre andré
hulk hogan dure depuis un moment et
s'intensifie et ce clash sans arrêt à la
télé c'était peut-être le premier faux
drame a monté toute pièce qui a pris
autant d'ampleur et là ça y est ils vont
s'affronter sur le ring 93 mille
spectateurs dans la salle des millions
téléspectateurs devant leur télé ce qui
est pour l'époque un record
absolue d'un spectacle en salle la
cloche sonne et ça fait mal au coeur on
voit qu andré souffre chaque mouvement
qu'il fait lui fait mal et il lui faut
des temps de pause on voit qu'il a pas
trop de plaisir à être sur le ring mais
qui le fait quand même
pour les fans hulk hogan gagne après
avoir soulevé et projeté au sol
andre the giant et pour l'anecdote
sachez qu'ils scénique et le dos parce
qu'il fait son poids l'ordre et même
pour hulk hogan
à partir de là hulk hogan reprend
définitivement le flambeau il devient le
nouveau favori mondial du catch et andré
lui entame une petite descente parce que
bah il est de moins en moins capable de
monter sur le ring et quand il monte sur
le ring c'est plus du tout aussi
impressionnant qu'avant sa souffrance
commence à être vraiment visible et donc
forcément il intéresse moins les gens
qu'avant il fait sa dernière apparition
à la télévision américaine en 1992 pour
le lancement des clash of the champions
et c'est vachement triste parce que
quand on voit ses grandeurs sur le ring
ce qu'il a proposé le personnage que
c'était ce qu'il dégage est malade un
coup tu le vois en béquilles tu vois
qu'il a le teint jaune qu'il a l'air
épuisé à bout de force et ça fait mal au
coeur en janvier 93
il rentre en france après avoir appris
le décès de son père il veut être
présent à ses funérailles et comptait
aussi resté plusieurs semaines pour
passer un peu de temps avec sa maman
mais quelques jours après les
funérailles de son père il va décéder
dans la nuit du 27 janvier d'une
insuffisance cardiaque
c'est là que la vie d'andré rené hauss
imhoff s'arrête et [ __ ] il nous aura
régalé
voilà ça m'a touché son histoire parce
que le gars avait vraiment un vrai
handicap physique c'est pas cool d'être
anormalement grand et lourd c'est tout
l'un vers sauf que lui il en a fait sa
force
et c'était resté un mec jean méga cool
mes gars gentil mais gabon mood chez pas
et dégager un truc sympathique et puis
ça reste un de ces français qui ont
marqué le monde en fait dans une
discipline et je trouve ça beau pour ce
conte qui fait sachez que ej bio ont
fait un documentaire sur andré qui est
probablement dix fois mieux que cette
vidéo soyons très honnête et il ya aussi
un livre qui s'appelle la huitième
merveille du monde
l'histoire vraie tendresse jaillet voilà
ci en actions curieux à son égard
n'hésitez pas j'espère que ce petit
format où je vous raconte l'histoire
d'une incroyable vous plaît moi j'adore
les gars j'adore découvrir l'existence
du minck ont fait qu une vie atypique où
une vie vraiment ouf
et je trouve qu andré en fait partie
bref c'est la fin de cette vidéo
j'espère qu'elle vous a plu à très vite
[Musique]